good good yeah so yeah obviously I don't
subscribe to the Trinity at all because
the Bible actually does not teach a
Triune God and what does the bible teach
it teaches that the father is the most
high God not Jesus Christ and I say that
because Jesus actually has a God so
there's no way you can be the most high
God and the father created him which
would destroy that Eternal what do you
mean the most high God
you said what you said a most high god
what do you mean no I said a most high
God yeah what do you mean oh most high
God yeah most high God I'm saying the
father is the most high God and Jesus's
God is the father so therefore he cannot
be the most high God if you have a God
that doesn't really make sense and the
father created him so they can't really
be co-eternal well let's start let's
start with that you have a lot of
misconceptions there let's start with
that where does where does it say that
the father created
Jesus well
first I would go there's plenty I can
there's I probably have like four or
five but if let's let's get one before
you bring that up too let me just make
sure I understand you correctly so the
most high is the only one who is
uncreated who has always you agree
correct he's the highest there's no one
yeah so so if Jesus was uncreated if he
always existed then that would mean by
virt by virtue of that he would be the
most high right he's not uncreated I
know if he was if he was was he would be
the most high is that right yeah but
he's not uncreated okay cool all right
all right let's get there what's the
verse that you have that shows that
Jesus is well I would go Revelation
three as a proof text first first I
would start first well yeah Revelation 3
and14 proves he was created all right
but I want to start at three Revelation
3 and12 because is important it says him
that overcometh will I make a pillar in
a temple of my God and he shall go no
more out and I'll write upon the name of
my God so what's the name of Jesus's God
Yahweh and you believe he is Yahweh even
though the name of his God is Yahweh
yeah can you keep reading and the name
of the city of my God which is New
Jerusalem which cometh down out of
Heaven from my God and I'll write upon
him the my new name so four different
times he says he has a
god correct he's in heaven saying this
yeah are you gonna keep
reading he that has an ear let here what
the spirit sayith unto the churches and
in Revelation 3:14 and unto the angel of
the Church of lotus SCS right these
things sayith the amen the faithful and
true witness the beginning of the
creation of God so Jesus Christ
admitting that he's the beginning of the
creation of God do you agree with the
text I I totally agree with that Amen to
that he's the agree that he was created
by God correct that's not what it says
it says he's the what it says okay so
let me ask you this um if
if you create your business are you the
beginning of your
business I know where you're going just
just answer yes so you're the beginning
of your business if you created
it I mean yeah you created the business
so you started it beginning is a
starting point exactly exactly so this
isn't saying that Jesus was created it's
saying that he's the beginning of
creation meaning he started it he
created it all that's
not well we just have to disagree on
that interpretation let me we don't have
to disagree on any interpretation let me
show you the word for beginning there is
RK do you know what RK means it can mean
it could also mean origin which is a
starting point ah so if you are the
origin of creation are you created
yourself but that's not it's saying he's
it's saying he was the beginning of the
creation of God meaning that's the first
thing that God created does it doesn't
say that it says that he the AR the
beginning origin ruler God doesn't have
an origin though you know what origin
means is God the origin of all
creation yes he's a starting
point but that's not what it's saying
it's saying he has a origin no it
doesn't where does it say that he has an
origin it's saying he's the beginning of
the creation of God so does it say I got
you does it say he is the beginning or
does it say he has a
beginning he has a beginning okay let's
let's bring it up let's see how how
dishonest you are brother you're not
going to last long if you lie seriously
all right we'll be I'll be honest let's
be honest okay so let's let's pull it up
one last time I'm gonna give you a
chance to be
honest the beginning of God's creation
does it say that he has a beginning or
that he is the
beginning but he's saying he's the
beginning of God not answer my question
okay does it say that he has a beginning
or does it say that he is the
beginning he is the beginning very good
so he is the beginning the arc or the
source the origin
right okay now let's break down let's
see what the Lexicon let's see how this
break how it breaks down this word here
let's see here oh here it is now I'mma
show you why I skipped one and two
because verse three is the context in
which you see how they quot it here
Revelation 34 that by which anything
begins to be the origin active
cause so in Revelation 3:14 it's saying
that Jesus is the origin the active
cause of God's
creation he is by that by which God's
creation began to be so he's not part of
creation he is Creator he created it
all that's fine
so so that verse is saying that Jesus is
uncreated
right no it's not it's actually not how
okay how can it be how is he created if
he is by which all of creation began no
well I believe that the first thing that
the father created was his son and he
used the son to create all things so
created all things except himself yeah
show me where it says that I can show
you just just as long as like
let's let me take a
breath I I I don't know how how it is
being on that other side you know
being a non-trinitarian and reading
coming up you know
like you know being um involved with
these
texts so I I mean like as a trinitarian
I can read this I can see how it what it
I you know it's pretty clear to me but
for you guys as non trinitarians you
guys have to act like you don't see
something or be dishonest with the text
um you make up stuff like you guys have
to do this I'm begging you for the sake
of this argument for the sake of our
discussion and our new friendship that
we are creating
today to be
honest can you do that with me can you
be honest yeah but when you go two
verses up he's saying he has a God so
your understanding would kind of be
wrong what trust me we will break this
down in a second I promise you yeah but
first yeah but we can be honest yeah y
let's be honest okay see I can be honest
and say yeah the text says and yetep
Jesus is in heaven saying that the
father is his God no problem I have no
problem I'm saying that I'm GNA break
that down though and show you how and
why I can't say it doesn't say that
that'll be dishonest with me right so
with Jesus being the beginning the
origin of God's creation the active
cause of it the source of God's creation
this means that he is outside of
creation himself right no that isn't so
how can you be the source the origin the
active cause of a thing and be that
thing at the same time but the word Arc
doesn't only mean Source or that is what
it means it can also mean a starting
point so we would just have to disagree
on it okay so this is what I need you to
do um I need you to show me where it
says that Jesus is created yeah yeah but
can can we yeah I'll show that but can
we break down the fact that Jesus said
four different times that he has a god
while he's in heaven not in is is Jesus
human in heaven
you believe he's in the flesh in heaven
right now do you do
you can you prove that I'm not saying
he's not but can you prove it do you I'm
asking you what do you don't ask can you
just come on talk to me man let's have a
conversation well he's not on Earth
anymore he's in heaven yeah do you
believe that he's human in
heaven could you prove
it are you gonna answer do you believe
that or
not yes I believe he he may be in the
flesh still it's fine so then so then
what I need to prove it if you we we
agree I don't need to show it but
there's a problem with that do you
believe he's ever going to be out the
flesh no never so he's always he's going
to have a god
forever that's the humble position he
took the sacrifice that Jesus Took was
lowering
himself um making himself of no
reputation forever to accomplish the
salv the the salvific work for
mankind he is forever and humble
willingly in a humble state so this is
why Jesus Takes on flesh and he never
gets rid of this because if the day that
he does we no longer have a high priest
in heaven
right we no longer have a mediator
between man and God right yep so he
needs to remain man even in heaven in
order to be our mediator in order to be
our high priest he still has to have the
nature of man and as the nature of man
what does the Bible say when it comes to
flesh what does the Bible say when it
comes to flesh let me show
you see it on the screen Jeremiah 32:27
yep I'm the Lord the God of All Flesh
yep so because Jesus Takes on flesh the
father becomes his God once he takes on
flesh so it's that's a relation in
virtue of his flesh not his divine
nature
that's why Jesus who has two Natures
divine nature and a human nature because
he has a human nature he can say
rightfully that the father is his God
even in heaven because he still has
flesh all right so just to make it clear
he's always he's G to have a god forever
as so when he took on flesh right as
soon as he took on flesh that's when he
had a God and he's going to have that
God over him forever correct y watch
this you believe Psalm 22 is is about
Jesus right my God my go
Psalms Psalm 22 yeah go ahead you
familiar with it um I don't think so
okay oh I put Palms dang I sound like a
uar all right Psalms not
Palms so Psalm 22 these are the words of
the Messiah here now watch
this the words of the Messiah
says but I am a man I'm sorry but I am a
worm and not a man scorned by mankind
and despised by the people all who see
me mock me they make mouths at me they
wag their heads he trust in the Lord let
him deliver him let him rescue him for
he Delights in him they're mocking him
right he says yet you are he who took me
from the womb and made me trust you at
my mother's breast on you I was cast
from my birth
and from my mother's womb you have been
my
God so from the womb that's when the
father is the god of Jesus when he takes
on flesh not
before oh so you're saying he didn't
have a god before because he had a god
before because he didn't have a human
nature the father was not his God
because he didn't have a human nature
for the father to be God over him you
know he didn't have that virtue of that
so are you saying his God was in Yahweh
before he took on
flesh brother hear what I'm saying let
me hope I'm clear before he takes on
flesh with without flesh he he's not the
father is not God over him because he
doesn't have flesh right he only has
they have the same divine nature that
they're sharing so he's not God over
once he takes on
flesh per that flesh nature that human
nature the father becomes his God
pertaining to his
flesh that's why yeah I understand what
you're saying but I can show you verses
pre-incarnate Christ that he had the the
father was still his God before he came
in the flesh okay we we'll get to that
in a second show me where so show me
where the father created Jesus so I
broke down why Jesus says that the
father is his God we broke down you know
Revelation 3:14 him being the beginning
of the creation of God so now oh amen
amen to this amen amen so now show me
where Jesus was created where the father
created him first and then used him to
create everything else well first well
I'll say the best for last but first we
can go to Micah five I need I need your
best I need I need the best yes give me
the a straightforward verse I'm G to
show you where his Spirit was created I
wanna I I need to see where Jesus is
created all right let's
go John 5 and 26 this completely
destroys entire Trinity so if we go John
5 and 26 it says for as the father have
life in himself what does life in
himself
mean he's the source of
life and then it says so that he given
to the son to have life in himself so
did the father give the son life in
himself
yeah did did the son have life in
himself before the father gave it to him
it's he always had life in
himself hold on hold on the father is
always giving the son life in himself or
granting him to have life in himself
always but it says so
that go ahead go ahead see wait you want
me to continue yeah see no no because
your this is your verse so I'm trying to
show you how this doesn't this doesn't
help you matter fact it does because he
said he's saying he gave the son life so
how are they co-eternal if he gave the
son life
does it say he gave the son life there
yes what does life in himself mean there
gave granted him to have life in himself
so having life
himself there is no before it's an it's
it's an eternal for example imagine um
like the for example the sun right the
Sun in the sky as long as the sun is
Alive and Well the sun will always shine
light right uhhuh okay it would always
shine light now
imagine that um that the sun is eternal
it's infinite imagine that okay the Sun
in the sky is infinite this would mean
that the sun infinitely brings forth and
shines light
correct so the light is coming forth
from the sun it's because of the Sun and
its infinite nature that the bringing
forth of the light is also infinite and
never ceasing right mhm in the same way
you have the father who's the source of
the divine nature right the divine
nature the father is the source of the
divine nature the father is eternal and
infinite so he is eternally and
infinitely bringing forth be getting the
sun he begot the sun it's an eternal
begotten so he's giv the son eternal
life correct is that what you're saying
because because the father has life in
himself and he begets the son by virtue
of that the son also has life in
himself because yeah but you're missing
the point the father is giving it to him
so before the father gave it to him he
didn't have that proving that he cannot
let's let's go let's go back to the
analogy that I brought the sun is in the
sky is infinite but the sun that's the
sun's created the sun didn't always
exist you did you did you do you know
what an analogy is you know what an
analogy is yes go ahead so so an analogy
is just draw dra a comparison to of the
principle to prove a point right okay so
in this analogy the sun is eternal it's
infinite you working with me okay so if
the if the Sun is infinite then the
light that the sun shines is infinite as
well right uhhuh where does that light
that infinite light come
from God the Father I'm talking about
the Sun in the sky in the analogy follow
the analogy bro you okay yeah yeah I'm
good I'm good all right you following
the analogy yep okay where is the
infinite light of the sun where does
that light come from the Sun is infinite
where does the light come from where is
it shining from the Sun very good why is
that light
infinite because of the sun because of
the sun is infinite
right so the sun is granting or giving
um
basically uh uh infinitive ude to the
light right because of the virtue of the
sun being infinite
right
similarly the father who is infinite be
gets the
son so the son being
infinite being brought forth from the
father is also
infinite so there is not a point in time
there is no before the father did this
before it's it's it's automatic it's
it's necessary it's a necessary action
that's taking that the father is beting
the son eternally similarly to how if we
have an infinite son in the sky it's
eternally or infinitely bringing forth
light that's why the son can say son of
Jesus can say that the father has
granted him to have life in himself
because he is eternally begotten from
the
father there isn't a time where this
doesn't happen there isn't a time where
this began to happen it always
was
mhm so this verse actually proves that
Jesus shares the same nature as the
father and has life in himself because
the father has life in himself showing
that he's the most high and
uncreated so when it's saying he given
the son to have life in himself you're
saying that he always had life in
himself even though it's saying that he
gave it to the
son thanks for coming
bro let's see here
here Frank how you doing